geeks have eagerly been awaiting this
day for months and it's finally here yes
this is the ipad as you may have
suspected this is basically a giant ipod
touch but some interesting things happen
when you take that little screen and
blow it up to nine point seven inches it
basically becomes a completely different
device let's start with the screen
whether you're looking at a menu of
icons or browsing the web or looking at
photos this thing is bright and vivid
and in your face and it's also extremely
responsive put your finger on it and
flip through pictures it moves really
fast I've never seen a screen quite as
responsive or brilliant as this one it's
also got an accelerometer so it
reorganizes great at is browsing the web
its built-in version of Safari is fast
and responsive it's easy to use and web
pages look gorgeous you can basically go
anywhere on the web and look at anything
it looks just like it does on your
desktop except you're holding it in your
hand but there's one important exception
that's flash any website that uses
Adobe's Flash standard is not going to
work the webpage will work but anyplace
there's flash content you're going to
see a blank square with YouTube there's
also built in application on the iPad so
you can watch videos directly through
the application and they work just great
there the iPad it's got a built-in email
client and it will look really familiar
to you if you've used an iphone the
difference is that email messages take
up the whole screen and if you want to
see your inbox there's a little pop-up
screen here the big downside of using
the iPad for email is that it's actually
a little bit difficult to type on it
works just fine but you can't type very
fast one of the things I like about the
ipad is that you'll be able to extend it
by adding apps that you get through
apple's app store there's thousands of
apps for the ipad out there already some
of the ones we're particularly excited
about our Instapaper which lets you save
web pages for later and it reformats
them in a much more readable way
evernote which is a great note taking
application and i'm pretty excited about
some of the book and magazine apps out
there the fact that this has a gorgeous
screen and a really responsive graphics
processor means you can do some truly i
popping
with applications like the Google Maps
app you can browse around but if you
want to switch into Street View does
this great visual effect and there we
are this will probably be most useful
with the 3g version of the ipad that
doesn't come out until later this month
and that's because the 3g version has
built-in gps and the Wi-Fi only versions
do not have gps critics will bash the
ipad for what it doesn't have there's no
keyboard it doesn't support adobe flash
and you can't add software to it except
by going through apple's app store those
are all legitimate problems and even a
netbook can do more than the ipad can
it's not going to replace your laptop
but what it is really good at is
consuming media is it worth 500 eight
hundred dollars probably not if you're
an early adopter and you get excited
about new gadgets it's a beautiful
device five hundred bucks is probably
not too much to spend the rest of us
should probably wait about a year the
price will come down and everyone will
have one